In today's video,
we're going to be teaming up
with Flite Test to see
if we can build a toilet
that flies through the skies.
[Music]
What are we doing
with all this foam, Nate?
Guys, we've got a lot of foam,
and we are going to turn
it into a toilet.
Fully functioning toilet.
Is that right?
No.
Yeah, he's gonna test it.
That's not going
to happen either.
He even brought his own poop.
We will have something
that lets us use the poop.
However, it will not be
a fully plumbed toilet,
because it's going to be made
out of Styrofoam.
But what's even cooler
about it is we are going
to take this toilet,
after we've carved it,
we're going to put in a box,
and we're going to ship it over
to the guys at Flite Test.
So the guys over
at flight tests are incredible.
They make things fly
that shouldn't fly.
So, why not a toilet?
Here's the basic idea.
We've got a lot
of white styrofoam.
We're going to stack it up,
and glue it together,
and then carve it
into the shape of a toilet.
It will then be shipped
to Flite Test,
who's going to attach wings
and make it soar.
They've got wings,
they've got motors,
they've got rotors,
and with all of that added on,
they should be able
to take our toilet shape
and make it fly.
One other thing we
are hoping to do,
we want to take the toilet,
like a back of it,
where the plumbing
would come out,
and make a little chamber
for our poop emoji.
So that by remote control,
they can make it drop
out of the toilet onto whoever
happens to be below.
Let's cut up some
sheets of Styrofoam,
and glue them together
using expanding foam.
♫ Everybody is Kung Fu fighting. ♫
On... You just...
There we go.
Yeah, that's perfect.
[Music]
So we're going to
start carving this,
and we're going to turn
it toilet shaped,
and we're going to be using like
saws and stuff to cut it up.
So the reason
that were using this type
of foam instead of the usual
smooth insulation foam is,
while that does have
a nicer finish, this
is going to be a lot lighter,
it's probably going to fly
a little bit easier.
It's also easier to carve,
and it's the color that we
want it to end up, white.
[Music]
We are not super concerned
with getting exact measurements
for any particular toilet.
There's thousands of types
of toilets in the world.
Everyone has a different design,
and as long as we have something
that's generally toilet shaped,
we're going to be
pretty happy with it.
But I do just want to get
a couple measurements,
like okay the back to tank,
it's about 18 inches wide,
8 or 9 inches deep,
and 16-17 inches tall.
[Music]
The styro-slicer might be good
for fine details,
but in the beginning here,
there's really no good
way to do this.
[Music]
We've got our toilet,
and there's some pits and stuff
where the styrofoam
broke occasionally,
and so we're just gonna use
a little bit of spackle,
patch those up,
give that a 30-45
minutes it needs to dry,
and then we're going to paint
it all with white paint.
Hopefully, that'll give it
just a little bit more gloss,
and make a little
more toilet like,
as well as keeping it
from flaking off quite so much.
And then after that,
we're going to be adding
in a trapdoor,
and some poop.
Yeah.
[Music]
Our toilet has now dried.
We've put all the spackle
and the paint on it,
and it's still
in two separate pieces.
So the tank comes off,
and I'm about to mount that.
But I did go ahead,
and add a little trapdoor
on to the bottom.
So, how this is going to work,
we're going to have
our little poops,
and we're going to make
a parachute for a poop.
And then this thing right here,
drops open so we'll be able
to have our poop up
inside of the toilet,
and then the Flite Test guys
are going to probably
change out this latch.
So they have something on
with a remote control.
So while our toilet is flying
around, poop just fall out,
and they'll sail
down on parachutes
that look like toilet paper.
[Music]
We are gonna be adding
some expanding foam
into these as well to hold
them just a little bit more.
[Music]
We've got our toilet built,
our poops have their little
toilet paper parachutes.
We even have a poop cam.
Now, we're just gonna take
a couple minutes, and see
if we can throw
our parachute poops,
and get them to glide
down nicely into our bowl.
After that, we're going to be
sending this off to Flite Test,
and it's gonna be
up to them to make it fly.
There's like the tiniest bit
of breeze that direction,
so let's...
Uh-huh.
Not that much.
There wasn't that much breeze.
Oh boy.
[Music]
Oh, no, the breeze
is coming back towards us.
[Music]
Nope.
Slowest one yet.
Don't go on the roof.
[Music]
No.
Hi.
[Music]
Better.
Come on.
No!
[Music]
Yeah!
Nice.
All right.
I'm just gonna--
I win!
I'm gonna cheat.
Oh, I did it.
Yeah!
High-fives all around.
I'm proud of you.
Yeah!
Toilet's complete,
parachute poop is working great,
trap doors installed,
it's time to send this
off to Flite Test,
and take a look at
how they've turned this
into an airplane
that flies through the air.
Hopefully, dropping little
parachute poops on command.
What do you got, Dude?
Yeah.
I have a little present
from our friends
over at King of Random.
King of Random.
[Music]
We still gotta put wheels on it,
we still gotta put a lot
of extra items on,
last-minute moment things,
but I think,
we're less than 24 hours
of work away from having
this ready to fly.
Guys, if you want to see
more of this build,
or just what Flite Test did
to our toilet, head on over
to the Flite Test Channel.
They've got more for you to see.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you to Flite Test video,
showing you how they put
wings on this guy,
and got it to soar
through the air.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
If you hit this bomb the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to our channel.
That way, you'll never miss
out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.